but my friends there's also another
story we have where we can talk about
what you get when you vote for the likes
of bernie sanders or
not so much bernie but those who would
push
policies like bernie take a look at this
your image
why we got good ol bernie sanders and
he's he's sitting he's sitting in a
little chair and he's got these big old
mittens on
and this this photo became a very viral
meme it is bernie sanders at the
inauguration he's kind of just like
it was over with and a lot of people
mentioned those mittens were just so
awesome
oh my god amazing mittens right right
ian yeah they were they were beautiful
beautiful men's right what if i were to
tell you
that you will never be able to get those
mittens you fascist
no socialists you know why why the woman
who made those mittens went out of
business because the taxes were too high
and it destroyed
her business wow yeah yup the story from
the federalist
woman behind bernie sanders iconic
mittens quit making them because high
taxes killed her business how ironic
yeah that happened yeah it's like a fire
truck on fire
the guy who advocates for higher taxes
is wearing the mittens of someone who
can't make them anymore because taxes
destroyed her business i'd like to give
a round of applause again
you know look there's there's an
appropriate middle ground there's
negotiations and there's there's a way
to move forward but i think we see too
much on the left is
zealotry zealotry in the sense where
it's like
we didn't plan this we don't know what
the results will be but we really
believe it to be true so we're gonna do
it anyway
and so then you get this federalist says
the vermont school teacher who made
bernie sanders mittens featured in the
most recent viral meme
said she had to stop making them after
the federal government taxed her too
much
people have been contacting me thinking
they can get mittens and actually they
can't i don't have any more
i don't have much of a mitten business
anymore because it really wasn't worth
it
jen alice explained to slate independent
crafters get really taken for a ride by
the federal government
we get taxed to the nth degree and it
really it wasn't really worth it
pursuing that as a business
even as a side hustle oh man
a punch in the gut seriously
you know we've talked about it a lot a
lot of conservatives do free market
capitalist types
if you tax people too much there's no
incentive to actually do anything
why do it yep what do you get i kind of
lived that life man
i'm just skating right now because i
don't want to deal with it the taxes
yeah
the whole system is so annoying they
just want to take take take
regulate this regulate that like the
paperwork i mean i guess you will hire
someone else to do that stuff for you
which is great i guess if you get to
that point maybe but you still got to
pay attention if someone's handling your
finances
it's their finances so you still have to
maintain your finances
yep that's a good lesson that kanye west
talks about he's his own c
uh ceo or cfo cool yeah
well many people make the argument that
taxes are all about controlling and
keeping people in line and
how can you not believe that when the
government literally prints money
but yet we're still supposed to be given
a portion of our
income if we could still magically earn
it if if immigration didn't take it if
oversea
visas didn't take it we somehow
magically are able to sustain for
ourselves and when we still have to give
a huge
cut to the government that that is going
to spend it on most likely war
i mean like are you kidding me you see
look look
when we talk about taxes the left and
the left and the right usually have the
wrong conversation i love the who will
build the rhodes conversation with
libertarians right
so a lot of people on the left when
talking with and caps and libertarians
say
but who will pay for the roads and then
you actually get an argument and the
libertarians will say
it's going to be a private company who
maintains the roads and maybe there will
be a toll and i'm sitting there going
like uh-huh
uh-huh let me ask you the real question
who's going to bomb the kids
who's going to who's going to blow the
kids up oh guess what nobody
because there's no incentive in any
market to do it i'm not a lazy fair
capitalist mind you
okay you know i think there's problems
with overgrowth of monopolies and
monopolistic power and
i don't know a lot of people in super
chats often disagree but i will tell you
one thing
the question should be not who will
build the roads i'll tell you this
i will take no road you can give me dirt
i will crawl through rocks
if it means we're not paying for the
blowing up of people in foreign
countries which i don't like yeah i'll
gladly take an off-road vehicle if it
means not having roads if we're not
going to be bombing the crap out of the
middle east and sending troops
all over the entire world and
threatening huge geopolitical conflicts
with other
world powers yes i'll gladly do that in
a heartbeat and people need to
understand
that michael bloomberg another kind of
uh you know scrooge scrooge-like
individual has has made arguments that
that taxes and regulations are necessary
for
control of of the populations in order
to keep them in line lydia you have
something right yeah so do you guys
remember when domino's pizza decided to
fix the potholes in the roads
better yeah there's a little company
yeah who will build the roads
domino's pizza will yeah what no they
won't they did
they literally did there was even an
adult website that paved
uh the roads in the northeast after a
major snowstorm
because the government was having
troubles doing it that's cool so
you know there's there's a lot of
stories of of people coming to
each other's needs helping each other
out without the involvement of a
middleman
when you have a middleman that's when
you have government when you have people
solving each other's problems working
uh with each other bartering trading
that's called anarchy
and we have a lot of anarchy that no one
really wants and you know what i've
admit
you know what really bothers me too you
know the government's not even really
that good at blowing up kids
private security forces are way better
at killing civilians
well they spend a lot of money on it
especially when you look at the coffers
when you look at the budgets when you
see the trillions of dollars missing in
the pentagon
you're like wait wait where did this
money go these other guys have flip
flops
these other guys have literal little
cloth on
that's not even made as as proper
clothing and and you're
and if they're lucky they have an ak
but but we have to send hundreds of
thousands of dollars at one missile to
blow them up
why somewhere thousands of thousands of
miles away from us
why this doesn't make any sense so i
think this is a classic case of when you
give people money they will rise to meet
whatever you will give them because
i found this to be the case with
military budgeting so with the planes
and stuff they're like well we won't
charge as much
unless they'll pay this much like donald
trump found that
the plane uh makers would make planes
for like
one half the costs they're like well we
were just making planes because this is
what they would give us
like that's capitalism for you but at
the same time it's like if the
government subsidizes it that's an issue
that's not capitalism right you have
socialism
yeah when the government says we're
going to be listen
you should think about money in terms of
buying power and access to resources and
not
you know people think about money think
about a number a hundred dollars five
hundred dollars a thousand no no think
about what you can get for it
if you make 15 bucks an hour i don't
care i don't i i don't care
listen right now you got all these
lefties saying we should get 15
an hour living wage okay so here's what
the government's done
you will get your raise quick print
money to reduce their buying power so
they don't actually get anything
if you can only buy you know let's say
15 buys you
a pair of blue jeans and then they give
you a raise of 15 an hour but then
increase the cost of blue jeans to 30
bucks you didn't get a raise
you just think you did and that's a
brilliant way to keep people
dumb and happy yeah i got a big raise
well there's a reason a lot of the top
billionaires call for more taxes and
more regulations because it
kills and squeezes out their competitors
anyone who's willing to compete against
them anyone
who could defeat them anyone who could
overcome them
is is burdened with all these other
things that they have to deal with
when these guys could just skate right
through it it's no issue for them it's
not a problem for them but everyone else
is going to be struggling
there's there's a picture of this pool
and it's showing a little small business
and it's showing an adult in there the
adult is
amazon it's all these other top big
companies
and then the little kids are small
businesses and it's a pool and they're
drowning in it
and the water are our regulations and
taxes so that's essentially what's
happening now and sadly this poor lady
i mean those mittens look look pretty
cool
they look really nice but but sadly
people are going to have to go to
amazon to get their chinese-made mittens
by the uyghur muslim population most
likely according to my own personal
opinion
uh everything's incentivized you ever
see those things where like someone will
buy a box of like i don't know combs in
the open is a note saying i'm trapped in
a factory in china please say yeah i
have not seen that yeah you've never
seen those before
yeah cause people working in the
factories are essentially slaves and
they'll write like please save us
and they'll put it in the box hoping
somebody gets it there's news stories
with pictures of that stuff
but the current system that we're living
on leaves us no choice
but to go to amazon because there's no
other place to potentially buy
mittens made by the average person the
average human being the average
entrepreneur that is trying to make
their way
in this really complex really hard
economically hit
the united states it's so funny because
i could make mittens and give them to
you
but if i make mittens and sell them to
you government's like hey
we want 35 of that yeah and on top of
that
sales tax in certain states i mean
are you kidding me thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you